bah oui au rangement du campement pliage
des tentes
c'est la fin des vacances pour ces
touristes alsaciens on connaissait pas
le coin on est venu parce qu'on avait
entendu parler de du coin donc on est
venu découvrir ces super au bord de la
rivière et avec la montagne à côté
c'était des vacanciers séduit ils ne
sont pas les seuls ce camping jurassien
affiché complet du 15 juillet au 15 août
cette année notre chiffre d'affaires
d'un mois et demi est équivalent au
chiffre d'affaires de 3 mois de l'année
dernière on a eu quelques personnes
habituel qui venait une semaine qu'un
jour on a même des gens qui sont là
depuis le début juillet qui sont
toujours sur le camping
même constat à 15 km de là à saint
laurent en grandvaux
on prend tous ces retraités haut saônois
ont déjà repoussé la date de leur départ
à trois reprises
on prolonge on aimerait bien même rester
plus nous du fait qu'on est à la
retraite
mais bon on a l'impératif dallaire
conduire les petits-enfants sinon je
pense qu'on sera resté là encore jusqu'à
la mi-septembre sans problème malgré une
bonne fréquentation et une augmentation
du chiffre d'affaires de 30%
la responsable de ce camping n'oublie
pas le confinement normalement non on
travaille toute l'année bah mars il a
fallu rembourser tout le monde je pense
qu'on va rattraper plusieurs mois de
fermeture un bilan d'été plutôt positif
2020 est décidément une année
particulière pour les professionnels du
tourisme les prochains mois pourrait
bien être déterminant pour bon nombre
d'entre eux